[Music]
even after my PhD when I couldn't land
in a job I realized that my skills have
become
[Music]
redundant I had come back from South
Korea and restarting my career is a big
big challenge for
me hello I'm gri we live in Bangalore
with family my education has been in
mechanical engineering I was working as
an assistant professor in garaja
rangaraju Institute of Technology
Hyderabad I left it in
2014 we moved to South Korea for a
period of 2 years along with my husband
for an on-site when I came back I was
looking for jobs and things didn't work
out for me then I completed my PhD but
still I could not find a better job
meanwhile I started a weekend restaurant
in my own kitchen but I wanted to to get
back to the workforce since I knew that
mechanical engineering would not alone
do I decided to take up a course in
artificial intelligence as it was in
huge demand so I went to Simply learn
artificial intelligence engineer Masters
course this course opened many doors for
me I was considered to teach artificial
engineering along with mechanical
engineering by my Institute New Horizon
College of Engineering Bangalore this
course helped me stand out from the
crowd they immediately appointed me as a
senior assistant
professor this course is so user
friendly and easily understandable and
it's more than enough to teach bch level
students I still refer this course to
teach my students so I recommend anyone
to take up this course who wanted to
start their career with AI it worked for
[Music]
me